Ella Louisa was only 10 months old when
she died but they were 10 months of
suffering and experience her mother
Linda will never forget euthanasia was
legally not an option but her mother
says it would have been a relief yeah if
you want your baby to live it should be
in a nice way not the way she was and it
hurts so much to see your child suffer
lawmakers in Belgium say they want to
relieve the suffering of terminally ill
miners the legislation is hugely
controversial and full of strict
requirements there has to be parental
consent extreme pain and the most
contentious the child must be able to
decide opponents say the choice of
whether to live or die is too much to
ask of children the very idea of a child
which decide on his own death because a
six years old tag for instance has that
the very concept of death complex
ethical issues are at the core of the
debate but critics of the legislation
seem to be losing the battle the law has
widespread support in Belgium's lower
house of parliament where it's expected
to pass